y el cambio de nombre llega cuando el
gigante de las redes es sometido a un
escrutinio de varios gobiernos tras
denuncias de que sus plataformas han
privilegiado las ganancias sobre los
derechos humanos y que han servido
también de plataforma para extremismos
es casualidad que el lanzamiento sea
precisamente ahora es difícil decirlo no
podemos asegurar que facebook tuviera
planes de alguna manera de distraer a
las audiencias frente a sus crisis sin
embargo si podemos decir que los planes
de facebook en materia de realidad
virtual y aumentada venían desde hace
unos años atrás y que desde 2018 venían
diciendo que el negocio iba a apuntar
precisamente a esta idea del metaverso
tal vez se aceleró el cambio de nombre
pero no podríamos decir a ciencia cierta
si fue es específicamente una respuesta
a la crisis de reputación que están
viviendo bueno y entretanto mark
zuckerberg ha dicho que la mejor manera
de proteger la seguridad y la privacidad
de los usuarios es a través del
metaverso que tan cierto es esto
hay que esperar a que empiecen a
desplegar sus opciones sin embargo es
una buena noticia porque pareciera que
la compañía de menlo park aprendió la
lección y entiende que no solamente es
innovar frente a cómo interactúan las
personas sino también pensar en los
riesgos y en cómo la apertura a la
interacción también puede dar paso a
brechas de seguridad a temas de
privacidad hay que esperar se supone que
ya tienen un protocolo frente a algunos
mínimos de seguridad y de privacidad que
van a ser parte de sus soluciones en
videojuegos en oculus en redes sociales
pero parece una buena noticia en un
principio hay que esperar que lo cumpla
sin embargo este lanzamiento no tiene
nada que ver con por ejemplo las
denuncias de la afectaciones de salud
mental de los jóvenes y de los niños por
ejemplo por el uso prolongado de
instagram a no hay ninguna
responsabilidad al respecto ahora con
este meta vers
en este momento lo que dicen es que más
que pasar más tiempo en las pantallas
quieren que la experiencia de internet
sea algo mucho más experiencial valga la
redundancia y se sienta en vez de
simplemente mirar internet
digamos la esperanza que tiene el neta
es que la experiencia digital se
convierta en algo que una de las
personas en compartir juntas y no
necesariamente en mirar una pantalla sin
embargo eso hace parte de un statement y
todavía no podríamos saber cuál va a ser
la realidad de los jóvenes que van a ser
los usuarios de esta tecnología sin
embargo la responsabilidad de los
jóvenes frente a las pantallas no es
solamente de la compañía sino también
por supuesto de nosotros como usuarios y
también de las distintas organizaciones
familiares e instituciones frente a cómo
estamos viviendo la tecnología